bet you didn't think he'd be asked this
question when he called into the show
co-founder of 35 ventures and the
business partner of one kevin durant uh
rich kleinman how are you rich
what's up staten island how are you
doing guys i'm doing just fine we're
again you're long island right you're
long island right now i am in long
island originally though where are you
from originally
new york city manhattan right now
rich rich rich rich you say
new york city it's manhattan if i say
new york city staten island you say what
no you're right
that's why i i quickly corrected and
said manhattan
being that i'm on the phone with
shaolin's finest
thank you hey that couldn't be
inappropriate i got it all into new york
city i got judd apatow on at the end of
this hour he's got a new
new movie the king of staten island um
and so with pete davidson right
it's excellent is it it is rich i saw
these early screeners well i get judd
apatow to call into the show i'm one of
those hosts that doesn't you know
just doesn't say oh yes i've heard your
movie's great i say i've seen your film
because i prepare i'm the kevin durant
of broadcasting is basically what i'm
saying to put it in your
in your language i like it easy money
eisen
there we go do you want to chime in on
this poll question before we get to the
the world at hand uh it's you you hear
it cause i'm not gonna lie and tell you
i was listening okay
well done rich go ahead ask him hi rich
it's the 13th anniversary of the
sopranos finale please tell us you've
seen it
oh my god everyone of course so did
members-only jacket guy
kill tony at the end or not
well let's let me ask a more holistic
question oh god um
of myself first am i happy with how they
ended it
no right um i would have liked some
finality and
finale for now how do you say that
finality you got it
you'd like something you said closure
closure you want closure closure closure
and i personally think that
he should that he killed him that's my
thought process i think he did
of course he did why else do they got
six to eight seconds of silence
well so we got a dark screen he's
clearly saying this is over
that's it it's over and why did the show
never come back in the movie i mean well
we look i mean obviously rest in peace
at one point it was
impossible when he passed away but
before that there was no
talk of anything over there was over
over the er done not even not even
not even any prequel which everybody's
doing prequels now
i mean no prequel it's a mob show it's
over okay see rich and i are
locked up two riches right here rich
climbing here on the rich eyes
here's my segway speaking of closure so
uh no shot of kevin durant playing this
year huh
none no why why not is he not ready does
he not want to what what can you i mean
is he is he it's just you know like you
said
i mean you talked about your preparation
you talked about your mindset
and you know he nobody is a bigger
competitor
than him and you've seen that over the
last 13 years but
this is a it's a shotgun season it's
it's a lot of games in a short amount of
time it's
uh it's very unknown and he has a clock
on when his body was
supposed to be right and ready to play
you know so you got to stick to that
plan
okay and um has he been told by anyone
with a medical degree that you run the
risk um
even if again i imagine he'd be he'd be
back in some sort of training camp
um by the end of a season if the nets do
advance to a certain point
well if the nets advance there's still
not even a a shot of him
maybe showing up in disney world in any
way shape or form
what do you mean if they advance to like
yeah yeah yeah
they're still playing somehow in
september what do you think
what do you think oh my i mean
i i if i if i could call kevin you want
to i'd be more than happy to ask but i'm
asking you what do you think if they if
in the gym right now can't even get him
on the phone got it
i conference him but i can't even get on
the phone right now he's in the gym
working out
okay so there's 0.0 full bluetarsky that
he is playing
in this current iteration of an nba
season
yes what's that have you never seen
animal house oh i have i have but you
know i'm not gonna lie there's some
voids in my like classic movie resume
and i've seen it
but i don't i can't recite word for word
like i could
the karate kid i can't recite word for
word the way i could goodfellas so i've
seen it but i don't know
you put it so
[Music]
long story short you put the karate kid
up there with animal house it's it's
it's a little jarring but we can move
past it
uh no i did was i just leaned on like
the first movie i could think of that i
could go
like word for word on and i'm not
putting him in the same category but i
think when the dust settles like
it's generally it's a little maybe it's
more of my generation i'm not aging you
because you're probably what a year or
two oldest
we talked about yeah i know you're
you're in your early 40s right
so animal house like i was i was a kid
kid i saw it but like
didn't connect with me like that rich
kleiman here co-founder of 35 ventures
business partner of
kevin durant so what what do you hear
about the return of of the nba as we're
sitting here on june the 10th this is a
this is going to be attempted we all
know but how likely
would you say this is going to be that
there will be a finish
i feel like it's likely i think that the
nba is
um as diligent and a prepared
league in organization as there is adam
obviously we all know
has been able to lead the nba through
ups and downs and always does it with
grace and you don't think he's
going to make a decision without
covering every angle and
seeing everything twice and i don't
think you announce that unless you're
fully
intent on going ahead with it and i
think it makes sense and then you see
the mls is going to be there before them
which i think is
probably a good exercise for the
location
um and just to see how the league
operates there but i expect them to
fully be there
and um and what are you hearing about
what players will be allowed
to do once there what are you hearing
about
i don't know i've only read what i see
like i only read
what woj wrote about like if they leave
got to come back and be quarantined
but you know because i only work with
kevin i might speak to other guys but
i'm not
at the middle of this time in our world
getting in their
business on their return to play but
it's never been something i've really
thought about or tried to factor in just
because kevin wasn't doing it okay so
the the conversations you may have with
people in kevin's
orbit or stratosphere of player or
anybody that you've spoken to
would you say that the players are
lockstep and saying yes let's go to
disney world let's finish this thing up
yeah i mean i think i think like
anything else in the world right now
it's always with this like qualifier as
everyone wants to make sure that it's
safe and secure and
you know there's a lot of things right
now way more pressing than
covid and the return to play that's
going on in our country and i think that
people's
minds are occupied but the nba players i
would assume
want to be back want to play want to
compete
want to be able to be any source of
inspiration for our country and it's
needed right now and i think that um
i think that that the idea that there'd
be an asterisk next to this in any way
is
silly to me if anything the asterisks it
would represent that this season would
be harder than any other season you know
like
an asterix implies that you didn't have
as tough a challenge or as tough a
journey to get to the ultimate
championship or somebody else was hurt
or
whatever the season was cut short in
this case there's more obstacles and
challenges than ever before
i agree with you rich i mean shoot 70 of
the season's already been played that's
number one
then there's a several months off and
then you then you have to
show up in one spot uh with all sorts
of distractions i mean when i mean
distractions i'm not talking about mr
toad's wild ride
i'm talking about everything that you
normally do to get ready for a game and
play a game and try and win a
championship is totally out the window
and then you and that and that you i'm
assuming some players are bringing
family members or some are leaving them
home
i can't even imagine i don't i don't
think there'd be an asterisk at
all i think it would be a wow that was
one of the most
impressive championship seasons and one
that i hope
uh you know that we'll never forget and
home one we will never have to attempt
again
that's the way i hope they would go yeah
and i think that what's interesting
about it is
so the season stopped to a halt like
march 13th or something
they're gonna go back to play july 31st
that's five months so let's just even
say july first for when
training camp starts if you look at that
as like a traditional off season from
year to year there's teams that
just come back and aren't the same team
or there's teams that come back and
surprise you and are better than they
were the previous year so i think that
storyline is going to be somewhat
interesting
and teams that are younger that have
benefited from their home court that may
not
have that advantage or won't have that
advantage now so i think it's going to
be pretty exciting and i think there'll
be
surprises obviously the stars and the
best teams are the stars and the best
teams but
who let me ask you guys question who do
you guys like is there someone that you
think
is it lebron is there someone that
everyone unanimously wants to win this
now is there a team you guys all want to
see win this
huh look at you rich going all sports
talk radio on us here uh i don't i don't
think so
uh city man reach for manhattan
oh
the new yorker of me says come on let's
get durant out there
i know you said that rich rich rich from
manhattan um
you know rich from staten island's like
come on if the nets advance i want to
see durant
um yeah you know long time listener
uh long time host long time host first
time caller literally first time well
actually i have called into my own show
i think for me it's like i want to see
what the bucks do they've been the best
team in the league this year they've
really dominated the east giannis is the
clear mvp
and i want to see if they can put it all
together and take this one home
i want to see what the clippers do too
yeah i mean this is their best chance in
such a long time
and then this all uh occurs you know and
yeah
i think the clippers benefit in some
ways if you think about like
the home court advantage i'm not saying
that they don't have one but it's not
something we've necessarily like
attributed to the clippers and one
through ten
they're like veterans who have played on
the big stage who have won
who are fourth quarter players i mean
they're loaded but
clear-cut mvp giannis wow so are you
saying rich are you saying
um that the there's really no clear-cut
home-court advantage for the clippers
because uh durant once dropped
uh 50 and then turned to the fans and
said who do you think you know don't
forget my name or something like that
didn't you do something like that
and that was before
and uh jimmy brooks and all those famous
clipper fans and he's like punking him
i think that's happening well i wouldn't
say punk in them and and i i'm not
saying the clippers don't have a home
court advantage he did put up i think
was like 48 right or was it 50.
i think it was it was a great game it's
one of the all-time great performances
that's for dogs
he was i mean he was i was not there no
i was not if i was there there'd be a
better home court advantage you know
wait richard who do you probably would
adapt it up too
two riches from the borough wait rich
who do you think is mvp
this year um
i don't know i just don't know if it's
clear-cut i mean you know i think that
like
i think there's no way to say i have
that conversation without having like a
strong
uh lebron argument to it um so
that was all it was clear cut is like
runaway there's been some runaways i
just didn't see it as a runaway
yeah i mean lebron was having a
remarkable lebron
lebron's also playing with another top
five player i mean giannis is playing
with like
the four of us that's pretty much is he
really playing i haven't seen del tufo
suiting up
for the box recently i'm ready to go in
code wow calling the rest of the bucks
the four of us that's quite something
i'll be honest with you and were you
including me
within the three of us he was in fact
including you um
hey rich uh what you know you mentioned
the mls going first
um in orlando before the nba the nba is
going to go before the nfl
so much conversation talking about what
is happening
in our world with uh protesting
and the murder of george floyd and
murders of brianna taylor and ahmad
aubry um
any conversation about what nba players
might do to
uh have a form of protest at all
uh i don't have any uh i'm not privy to
any of that but what i'll say is like
historically the nba players have always
been
on the forefront of speaking out about
being on the side of right about
advocating and some of the most astute
minds i've always felt this way i see it
in business i see it in philanthropy i
see it in
social activism and i expect nothing
different
especially because we're just living in
a scary yet
exciting time in that it feels like for
the first time ever the line between
right and wrong has truly been
drawn and um you know and people can't
really hide from that
and people are tired of it and it takes
a pandemic
and you know uh displeasure with federal
government all that kind of stuff for
people to
to start seeing it more clearly that
weren't at the forefront of it
and you know i think it's the time now
to keep hammering that message home
because you got to keep doing this and
keep doing this and making sure that
the roles of people in power are changed
and i expect nba
players to to uphold that because like i
said nobody's as outspoken and
and um influential in those
conversations as they are
rich i appreciate the call man always
enjoy our chats and catching up
and all that stuff sorry i was late i
blew three good minutes we could have
you know that's like a half of a pti
segment but that's okay don't worry
about it it's all good
uh i appreciate you guys i appreciate
you guys who's playing what position
with giannis when we suit up you know
okay well i assume you're tall rich what
are you measuring at these days dude i'm
like
six three but i i have that like you
know i like to model my game after one
mark action jackson so i will be
slow and methodical with how i bring the
ball to court but i'd like to run the
one
okay all right that sounds great i will
gladly play pj tucker i will stand in
the corner and shoot three
pj tucker you're like j.r smith you have
no conscience
all right that's fair to you that's
totally good for 12 and then take the
next
15 shots i'm okay with that as well i
forget that we're up against the break
i know what the score is at all times i
know what the score is at all oh boy
i see what i'm dealing with right here
rich that's all see look at this shooter
shoot man
that's you so that's why you're so savvy
let's just throw that out there and let
us argue
instead of me asking why durant's not
coming back you know i mean
switched him up all right guys he's
gotta
take it easy rich take care man that's
rich climate follow him
rich kleinman on twitter at 35 ventures
at boardroom as well for
the 35 ventures uh he is co-founded
with uh kevin durant and the boardroom's
a uh a terrific show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here